Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my new mandalorian season 2 grogu emperor
palpatine video everyone wondering what's the
connection between those two characters he's so
powerful of course he heard grogu's jedi beacon at
the end of episode six you also have all of moff
gideon's cloning which seems very similar to what
palpatine was doing in the star wars movies so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships
there's also going to be a very special
presentation for all the brand new star wars live
action stuff that they're doing with jon favreau
dave filoni and the larger universe they're
creating through the disney plus series that'll be
happening later today so of course i'll be doing
videos for that as well in addition to my regular
season 2 episode 7 video this week but after the
last few episodes of the mandalorian everyone was
wondering what the connection was between grogu
and emperor palpatine because grogo is so powerful
and if moff gideon is that interested in him of
course palpatine long term would be interested
in him as well and he would have known that he
was at the jedi temple so it wasn't like grogu
was a total secret he was just another jedi
padawan like all the other ones at the temple
so kitano answered a lot of those questions for
us thankfully kind of explaining where he fits
into the star wars prequel timeline he's about
the same age as anakin skywalker it's just that
he showed up at the jedi temple at the traditional
age you would normally show up when you were very
very young you just have to picture a much
much tinier version of grogu it's hard to say
how much he grew those first couple of years
but he's 50 years old so he'd already been at
the jedi temple for a couple years when anakin
skywalker showed up with qui-gon jin and obi-wan
kenobi also after witnessing all of moff gideon's
failed cloning experiments people are starting to
wonder if there is a connection to palpatine's
cloning experiments with all the snow clones in
the star wars movies the whole thing with that
is it's a big dark empire comic book easter egg
if you didn't read those in the dark empire comics
palpatine was trying to create clones of himself
because he wanted contingency plans that was
just one of his many backup plans should he die
he would just transfer his force spirit to another
one of his younger clones during the movies he
claims he literally created snoke but during
some of the expanded novels around the movies
they basically explained that snoke and palpatine
sensed each other from across the galaxy early on
so what probably happened is is that he learned
about snoke then started using him to perfect the
cloning process of making force sensitive clones
for himself so that once he did jump into another
clone the clone body would actually be able
to hold his force essence without completely
burning itself out the whole thing with grogu's
force beacon after episode six he sent through
the galaxy is that emperor palpatine would be one
of those people powerful enough to sense that even
as far away as the unknown regions which is where
he currently is in a semi-living state right now
so he is clocking grogu from afar during this
whole period though he only seemed like he was
dormant he's mostly just setting the stage for his
big return about 25 years later the reason why he
waited that long is just because it's taking that
long to build the final order fleet with all those
sith troopers the whole thing with force sensitive
clones though they kind of get into this in a lot
of the expanded material and of the other books
is that there's something about midichlorians that
makes it fundamentally almost impossible to clone
someone who's force sensitive in a perfect way
there always winds up being some sort of genetic
defect or the clones wind up going insane this
is also a big heir to the empire easter egg for
doris kaboth if you didn't read the thrawn trilogy
of books from back in the 90s they're amazing i
would recommend checking them out they're slowly
re-canonizing a lot of that stuff thanks to dave
filoni give him a big tip of the hat there's all
this stuff with cloning for sensitive people going
on in the new mandalorian episodes as well as the
new star wars movies they did that during the
thrawn trilogy starting with heir to the empire
thrawn wants to use a jedi master but learns
that he is a clone the clone winds up going
crazy just because of genetic defects but also
we find out one of the emperor's contingency
plans is that he used luke's severed hand from
empire strikes back to create a full-blown clone
of luke skywalker and use him against the
real luke they wind up fighting each other
they reference a little of this during the
mandalorian season 2 episode 4 with them trying
to clone force sensitive people where dr purging
is talking about injecting grogu's blood with its
high midichlorian count into human test subjects
the cloning subjects that you see in the tanks
but because of all the problems with trying to
clone midichlorians you see all these broken
misshapen snoke looking creations so of course
a lot of people had wondered with all this force
sensitive cloning if grogu was just a clone of
yoda there's a couple reasons why grogu isn't a
clone of yoda one because he was born long before
yoda died and trained at the jedi temple for years
before anakin skywalker showed up yoda would have
known him during that period yaddle too because
yoda would have had a vested interest in seeing
his species survive like the jedi normally weren't
allowed to marry and have children but jedi master
kia mundi for instance came from a race that was
extremely low in population so the jedi order made
an exception for him allowing him to have multiple
wives so that his species could continue so that
same would have been true for yoda like find as
many of my species around the galaxy as you can
because there aren't that many of us make all the
yoda yaddle harem jokes that you want i'm sure
they'll probably never fully explain that just
because george lucas is always so protective of
the yoda character and dave filoni wants to honor
that so i don't think they have any intention of
over explaining that part of yoda's history but
the other reason why grogo isn't a clone of yoda
is because after season 1 episode 3 when we saw dr
purging testing him on the bio bed with a medical
droid from a new hope john favreau and dave filoni
said that he was not a clone they also referenced
that during the actual episode as well there's no
evidence of him being a clone i think it might be
a strand cast i don't think it was engineered i've
worked in the gene farms this one looks evolved
that was also the episode where dr pershing took
the blood samples that he referenced during season
2 episode 4. he said they were only able to take
a little without killing him because physically
he's just so tiny he doesn't have that much blood
on him at the end of episode 6 when moff gideon
has the stormtrooper stun him and put them in
those tiny handcuffs they're on their way back
to another lap so dr pershing can drain him again
like a vampire that's why he says tell dr pershing
we have our donor so that they can continue their
cloning experiments a lot of people also thought
after episode four and then after episode six that
the whole cloning plot also had something to do
with moff gideon trying to make himself force
sensitive like could you take the dna from someone
who is very powerful in the forest like grogu
and combine it with someone else's dna to make
them force sensitive it's totally possible that's
one of his side goals but i don't think that's his
main goal with this cloning plot i think it's a
lot like the dark trooper storyline he's trying to
create a new army that he can control more easily
like the clones from attack of the clones in
the camino facility because dr purging's uniform
literally has the kamino emblem on it and he's
probably trying to enhance these clones any way
that he can like making them force sensitive the
dark troopers are kind of a version of that but in
the dark forces video game where they're pulling
this stuff from there were various versions of
them each time with new phases getting upgrades
making them more hardcore like they start out
looking a little more like regular droids but
then they become more like cyborgs with human
parts combined with droid parts to make them
superior in battle just from a design perspective
it seems like the ones in the show are somewhere
between phase 1 and phase 2 troopers but the dark
troopers are not moff gideon's only long-term
plan they're just part of it the cloning stuff
also probably has a couple different goals and
like i said they are pulling a lot of easter eggs
from the thrawn trilogy because now we have grand
admiral thrawn moff gideon is trying to bring the
empire back they haven't confirmed whether or
not he's directly working for emperor palpatine
or if he knows about all of palpatine's long-term
contingency plans we just hear him say long live
the empire like he wants the empire he knew the
old empire to continue if you didn't read a lot
of the newer books after the battle of endor when
the empire lost the rebellion in the new republic
which was in the process of forming forced them
to sign a treaty saying that they wouldn't ever
try to come back they would basically disband the
rest of the empire after that a bunch of rogue
imperial admirals rallied tried to come back again
that resulted in the battle of jakku which is the
actual final battle of the empire then during that
one of the other imperial admirals staged a coup
within the remnants of the empire and took their
fleet into the unknown regions to become the first
order that was all separate from what palpatine
was doing so not everyone within the empire even
up at the higher echelons in the admiralty knew
what palpatine's plans were so it stands to reason
that moff gideon thinks all this stuff that he's
doing is just his plan in grand admiral thrawns
but really behind the scenes palpatine is just
manipulating them from afar letting them think
that they're doing this for themselves when really
they're just setting the stage for his eventual
return that's why palpatine probably knows
about grogu now and why he isn't sending sith
agents like the knights of ren to go bring him
back to exigle because he wants to see if moff
gideon's cloning plan is successful and it's
much more efficient to let that play out and
if he's successful just swoop in and steal
all that research and benefit for himself
and you have to consider that the story that jon
favreau and dave filoni are interested in telling
through the mandalorian in these new series are
about new characters that they created like Moff
gideon denjarin the mandalorian and grogu they
didn't create grand admiral thrawn but he's also
a newer character that hasn't been used in the
movies and he wasn't directly created by george
lucas like a lot of the other characters he
was created by timothy zahn for the thrawn
trilogy back in the 90s that's why we probably
won't see a ton of palpatine stuff play out on
the mandalorian series but in the way that dave
filoni sort of used the final season of clone wars
to tell a broader revenge of the sith storyline
like make the movies better they're probably
doing the same thing with the mandalorian series
weaving it into the movie continuity making the
movies better by default with ahsoka tano and all
these other characters they've kind of already
done that with grogu weaving him into the prequel
movies timeline explaining how he could have been
a jedi padawan at the temple at the same time as
anakin skywalker and when ahsoka tano tells us
about grogu's backstory explaining how his memory
went dark after a mystery jedi or mystery person
rescued him before order 66 memory manipulation
is a very powerful force technique they call it
force rub the biggest time you see it used in the
cannon is during the clone wars mortise arc when
the father uses it on anakin skywalker to erase
his memory of his future destiny is darth vader
after the sun the living aspect of the dark side
of the force spoiled him on it big spoiler alert
you're going to wind up killing most of the
jedi order pretty soon so it's possible that
whoever rescued grogu used that on his mind
to erase his memories of all those events
and it's not an exclusive light side or dark side
ability so i've seen a lot of theories that the
person who rescued him could have been a dark
side or a sith force user in addition to some of
the more common jedi theories i do think that the
show is going to reveal who it was that saved him
but they don't seem like they're in a big rush
to do that and it might not necessarily be the
jedi that shows up to answer grogu's beacon but
i am expecting that jedi who answers his beacon
to actually be teased in the season 2 finale even
if we don't actually see them on screen in early
prediction it will probably wind up being another
newer character that we haven't seen in live
action before like one of the animated characters
coming into live action it would be amazing to see
mace windu or a version of luke skywalker show
up because logically luke skywalker should hear
the beacon but i think it's more likely that dave
filoni and john favreau will use the opportunity
that they've done in the past to introduce new
stuff like ezra bridger is at the top of my list
but there's also characters like kyle katarn
because of all the dark forces easter eggs with
the dark troopers there's quinlan vos there's
calcus from the jedi fallen order game or they
could just wind up creating someone completely
new let me know in the comments though do you
think that moff gideon's cloning experiments is
directly related to emperor palpatine's cloning
experiments do you think he's secretly working
for him long term and do you think that the jedi
who's going to show up to answer grogu's call
will be one of the animated characters or do
you think there'll be somebody from the movies
or even the expanded universe legends canon my
full mandalorian season 2 episode 7 video will
post tomorrow just like normal and there's also
a really big disney investor presentation later
today for a bunch of new star wars and marvel
live action series that they're doing so
i'll do a video for all that stuff as well
everyone click here for my full mandalorian season
2 episode 6 video and click here for my brand
new grogu luke skywalker video thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe this is the way!